please welcome back to the show Tabitha
Brown
oh my God
what are we making today you have this
gorgeous new book which I'm so excited
to discuss with you scene loved heard
um but we're gonna make a dish today
before we discuss that all right what
are we making so we're gonna make some
stuffed avocados okay these are going to
be raw so if you own I love oh I like
that okay
right so if you're on a journey to you
know attract a lot of people in the new
year or before the summer they try to do
a lot of raw foods right this is a great
one that's delicious and ain't gonna
spare no taste okay so shall we get
started let's do it okay I use pecans
for my meat substitute I love a pecan or
a walnut for meat substitute yes love
absolutely and you soak the pecans and
you put a little bit of mushroom oh yeah
it's a nice hearty good vibrances okay
and then we add some of these a nice
type of celery green pepper red pepper
and red onion and garlic come on and
tell the people I am very good
I will I'm gonna add a little bit
because listen I'm me and this food
processor we ain't we just met today and
that is a relationship
oh my God Tabitha you're making me have
an aha moment it's so true a food
processor a food processor is a little
bit like an elusive guy on a dating app
you don't really know how it's gonna
turn out is it gonna work are you ever
really gonna meet right you don't know
how much pressure to put on yeah okay
it's like is today the day it's gonna
work is today the day you're gonna like
not hear anything yep okay let's see if
we hear anything
all right so it immediately looks like
ground beef it does you see that
immediately the two Paul says and you've
got a vegan ground beef delicious a
great option which is like so like that
I love it now the things that I love to
put it very very good
so I like a little mango de gallo on top
okay is it extra flavor so we got mango
cilantro we have a little bit of
jalapeno if you like a little heat is
that your cumin you got a little well
that's garlic powder oh garlic powder
because that's my business
yep and then we got some more red bell
pepper and some more
um red or purple onion love that I don't
know why they call them red well I do
but they're right they
Tabitha I'm having another aha moment we
put a little lemon juice a little lime
juice purple you know why they call them
then why because when they named them
The Color Purple had not been discovered
yet it had not been made so they had to
call them red really that's what they
tell me
[Laughter]
all right so now we got our mango the
guy yeah
mango de gallo okay now we have our
avocado yes and we're gonna go ahead and
build it up stuff it and then you have
the fatty
um from the avocado those good fats this
is correct we got the protein and the
freshness from the mango de gallo it's a
perfect balanced dish actually I wanted
someone from the audience to come taste
this today yes because I am always the
one and I just thought you know what
where is Carter Calvert
come on here Burger covered
oh
I love it I I've never done this before
hi hi in my mind we're co-hosting oh we
are by the way yeah we absolutely are in
fact Co right over here take it away I'm
glad to help I mean so this is a little
cashew cheese okay okay
special business okay and you can also
put just a pinch of salt just a little
sea salt if that's what you want I mean
I want whatever's here all right we're
very good okay okay
[Applause]
[Music]
let's see
oh my God right
oh my God this is so cool for me this is
very so good yeah this is delicious
and I pay her okay I need a doggie bag
you know I I fell in love with you
amongst millions and millions and
millions of other people you're like
ASMR voice
um in fact it's Tabitha Brown ASMR has
more than get this number everybody you
ready buckle up
570 million listeners
I didn't even know that
and we have to go to a quick commercial
break I'm wondering will you will you do
your voice for the commercial will you
take it away I guess so let's see will
is this song we have to take a break but
don't you worry we're coming back and
when we do we're diving into my new book
so don't go nowhere because if you do we
might miss you all right we'll be right
back
[Music]